here and what we're gonna do is we're
gonna find the ray that bisects or cuts
this angle in half so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna open up our compass
okay we're going to put this point here
at the vertex so let me just rotate the
paper a little bit here for us okay and
what we're going to do is we're going to
draw an arc here and here so it
intersects the two sides of the truck of
the angle if you want you can just draw
one continuous arc so I'll just do that
like so and then what we're going to do
is we're going it use this point and
this point those two points of
intersection to make two more arcs so
I'm going to go back here okay
I'm gonna make an arc and what I usually
do is I make the arcs just a little bit
longer than I think that I'm gonna need
because I want to make sure that they
they intersect so I used that
intersection point now we're going to
use this intersection point over here
notice I didn't change how open or close
the compass was I kept that the same and
I'm going to draw another arc okay like
so and now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna draw a ray through this vertex
point and this intersection point and
that's gonna be our angle bisector so
let's go ahead and do that okay there
you go so you can see that this angle
right here is the same as that angle
right there and you can use a you know a
protractor to verify that but you can
see it's going right down the middle its
bisecting the angle cutting it in half
I'll see you in the next video